with respect to Baltimore let me make a
couple of points first obviously our
thoughts continue to be with the family
of Freddie gray understandably they want
answers and DOJ has opened an
investigation it is working with local
law enforcement to find out exactly what
happened and I think there should be
full transparency and accountability
second my thoughts are with the police
officers who were injured in last
night's disturbances it underscores that
that's a tough job and we have to keep
that in mind and my hope is that they
can heal and get back to work as soon as
possible
point number three there's no excuse for
the kind of violence that we saw
yesterday it is counterproductive when
individuals get crowbars and start
prying open doors to loot they're not
protesting they're not making a
statement they're stealing when they
burn down a building they're committing
arson and they're destroying and
undermining businesses and opportunities
in their own communities that robbed
jobs and opportunity from people in that
area so
it is entirely appropriate that the
mayor of Baltimore who I spoke to
yesterday and the governor who I spoke
to yesterday work to stop that kind of
senseless violence and destruction that
is not a protest that is not a statement
it's people a handful of people taking
advantage of a situation for their own
purposes and they need to be treated as
criminals point number four the violence
that happened yesterday distracted from
the fact that you had seen multiple days
of peaceful protesters that were focused
on entirely legitimate concerns of these
communities in Baltimore
led by clergy and community leaders and
they were constructive and they were
thoughtful and frankly didn't get that
much attention and one burning building
will be looped on television over and
over and over again and the thousands of
demonstrators who did it the right way I
think have been lost in the discussion
the overwhelming majority of the
community in Baltimore I think have
handled this appropriately expressing
real concern and outrage over the
possibility that our laws were not
applied evenly in the case of mr. great
and that accountability needs to exist
and I think we have to give them credit
my understanding is is you've got some
of the same organizers now going back
into these committees to try to clean up
in the aftermath of a handful of
protests a handful of criminals and
thugs who who tore up the place what
they were doing what those community
leaders and clergy and others were doing
that is a statement
that's the kind of organizing that needs
to take place if we're going to tackle
this problem and they deserve credit for
it and we should be lifting them up